every four years during the third week
of january
the presidential inauguration takes over
downtown washington d.c
okay it's uh saturday afternoon
about 2 30. and i'm about to
ride my bike into dc and
just do a kind of a loop around capital
mall it sounds like
you know this is going to be an
interesting
next few days so here we go
people come from across the country to
celebrate one of the hallmarks of our
democracy
the peaceful transfer of power excited
crowds bundled against the cold
line the parade route down pennsylvania
avenue fancy parties and events spill
out of hotel ballrooms all over town
it's kind of like a political mardi gras
that happens once every four years
national geographic's headquarters is
located just a few blocks from the white
house
so we're always kind of in the eye of
the storm so basically it's like the
whole mall
looks like it shut down the inauguration
of a u.s president is always a historic
event
since george washington took the first
presidential oath of office in 1789
inaugurations have been held during
times of war and peace
prosperity and uncertainty strong unity
and deep division
so how will history remember 2021 and
joe biden's inauguration
[Music]
i'm peter guinn editor-at-large at
national geographic
and i'm amy briggs executive editor of
national geographic history magazine
and this is overheard a show where we
eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at nachio
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
in this special episode we're heavy on
the weird the most surreal presidential
inauguration
in recent memory we venture into the
streets of the nation's capital to talk
to nachio photographers reporting on the
inauguration
and we'll also see where 2021 fits into
the history of u.s inaugurations
so peter you've been all over dc it's a
global pandemic
and the most security of any
inauguration in u.s history
yeah amy so i'm downtown uh right along
the parade route in a hotel room about a
block from the white house
inside three rings of security
perimeters you know
i've been talking to some of our
photographers that have been documenting
this
you know as you pointed out very unique
inauguration
including nina berman louis palou and
david gutenfelder
we actually watched the parade pass
right under the window here
the secret service actually knocked on
the door and told us
we had to keep the windows closed and
it's a prime view
looking down constitution avenue toward
the washington monument
you know it's one of those views that
makes you think about all the history
this city
and this country have seen so amy
as executive editor of history magazine
you're the perfect person to help us
understand this historic moment
i know you've been digging into past
inauguration so how did this process of
installing
a newly elected president get started
so we should set the scene it wasn't in
washington dc
it was in new york city which was our
capital back in 1789
when george washington was sworn in as
the first president of the united states
so funny story the swearing-in process
is supposed to happen in march
but winter weather delays the arrival
of everybody so the electoral ballots
don't show up on time
which pushes his ceremony from march
into april which
proves that electoral ballots have been
somewhat of a tricky business since the
beginning
but washington he takes the oath of
office and then he delivers a speech
it's the very first inaugural address
and in it he's thankful
he's humble he calls for national unity
and since then delivering a speech like
that has become a tradition that all
elected presidents have followed
from george washington to joe biden so
much of what washington did set the
standard for future presidents
including stepping away from power after
only two terms
okay so this is before presidents had
term limits
yep um so if george wanted to keep being
president
all he had to do was keep winning
elections and he had a lot of support at
the time
so he surprises everybody when he
decides after only two terms that he's
going to willingly step away
so he writes this farewell address in
1796
so if you're a hamilton fan you can hear
it in the song one last time it's in
that musical
they quote it directly which for history
nerd like me is very cool
so in the speech he explains his
decision but he's really also reminding
americans that the republic
is really a fragile and special thing
and that national unity would only keep
the republic strong
as long as they cherished it and
protected it
the unity of government which
constitutes you one people
is also now dear to you it is justly so
for it is a main pillar in the edifice
of your real independence
the support of your tranquility at home
your peace abroad
of your safety of your prosperity
of that very liberty which you so highly
prize
but as it is easy to foresee that from
different causes
and from different quarters much pains
will be taken
many artifices employed to weaken in
your minds the conviction of this truth
as this is the point in your political
fortress
against which the batteries of internal
and external enemies
will most constantly and actively though
often covertly and insidiously directed
it is of infinite moment that you should
properly estimate the immense value
of your national union to your
collective and individual happiness
so some heady stuff so what washington
is talking about here
this threat to unity is similar to
what's been plaguing our nation very
recently
which showed up in full force at the
capitol on january 6th
yes i'm always struck by washington's
integrity on this issue
i mean how many people in history ever
gave up power
when they had so many people urging them
to hang on to it
and you know now we are in the city that
bears his name
and it's been fascinating and you know
frankly disturbing to watch it transform
over the last several days
i was living here during 9 11 and there
wasn't anything close to the security
increase that we've seen just over the
last you know a few days before the
inauguration
a lot of capital police not sure which
way i can go here
you know it's hard even on a bicycle and
roaming around it's
it's it's really hard to see the city
and all the facets of this moment
as one person can i go this way
okay and it get like we called in half a
dozen photographers of all different
backgrounds and experiences and sent
them roaming across d.c
they've chronicled life and war and
elections and so much more in the u.s
and abroad in their other work
and one of those photographers is nina
berman this is the fifth inauguration
she's covered
and she told me normally what she sees
in an inauguration it's just a giant
party
but not this one let's listen the
restrictions are
you know way beyond anything i've ever
encountered before
um this city is kind of been depopulated
except for people
uh who are um you know working in the
inauguration or involved in security
outside of a certain zone you can see
kind of regular life gone in dc but
inside
the zones um kind of creepily called the
green zone like baghdad
it's it's really kind of a little bit
chilling
quiet ghost-like
the inauguration was already going to be
muted because of the pandemic
but then came january 6
that was the day a mob of president
trump's supporters stormed the capital
as congress was meeting to certify the
results of the election
respect photographer louie palu was
there
and louise not an easy guide of shock he
spent years traveling to the front lines
of afghanistan
and covering mexico's drug wars so he's
seen a lot of violent scenes
but i was curious to hear what he
thought about seeing an event like that
in the city he lives in it wasn't just a
protest
i think it was one of the most
destructive moments in this country's
history because
it's about it's in that building and
that the people in it that are elected
it's it's what this entire it's what
everything is based on
from from the revolution through the
civil war
and i just think that what they did was
they damaged something that you can't
just glue back together
or or put some tape on and put some
nails i think
we'll recover like you know i try and
think of things like pearl harbor
you know 911 uh and other moments like
that
but i think that this has a different
thing because
they actually attacked the house where
everybody's democratically elected
officials
create policy and do things for the
entire country
from rich to poor to white to black
everything everything happens in that
building
and just so many centuries of putting
that all together
they bruised it they damaged it you know
honestly i think we're all still trying
to process that day
you know the way louis describes the
violence at the capitol
makes me think of abraham lincoln's 1861
inauguration
there wasn't any violence there that day
but the civil war is on the horizon and
temperatures around the country are
running hot
you know lincoln even had to be snuck
into washington dc
to thwart a conspiracy to kill him it
was called the baltimore plot before he
took office
so in his inaugural speech lincoln
appeals to national unity to keep
southern states from seceding
but he also warns them in your hands
my dissatisfied fellow countrymen and
not in mine
is the momentous issue of civil war the
government will not assail you
you can have no conflict without being
yourselves the aggressors
you have no oath registered in heaven to
destroy the government
while i shall have the most solemn one
to preserve protect
and defend it we're not enemies but
friends
we must not be enemies though passion
may have strained it must not break our
bonds of affection the mystic chords of
memory stretching from every battlefield
and patriot grave to every living heart
and hearthstone all over this broad land
will yet swell the chorus of the union
when again touched as surely they will
be by the better angels of our nature
that's a beautiful um you know
piece of lincoln speech though i i can't
remember
hearing that recently so that's so yeah
like when people talk about lincoln they
either they quote three speeches they
quote the house
divided they quote the gettysburg
address they quote the second inaugural
and the first one doesn't get the like
the big
love but you hear that phrase better
angels of our nature
you know whenever you hear presidents
use that they're calling back to lincoln
so they this this speech gets touched on
a lot although it doesn't get the big
giant love that his other ones do
so you know we know the issues that
caused the civil war
you know but how do we get to january
6th and you know by extension to the
massive lockdown on
in dc on inauguration day you can't get
over into that side right now
i got you okay yeah you know to
understand how we got here i think you
have to look back
you know at several events during 2020
that helped set the stage
so you know even before this we had sent
photographer david gutenfelder to
document the covet pandemic this is way
back you know in the spring as things
were getting going he lives in the
midwest
we wanted to see the effect of the
pandemic on the heartland
and then the protests that happened over
police brutality so he
started covering those david is another
one that's had a long career as a
foreign news photographer
you know originally for the associated
press he covered conflicts in africa
iraq afghanistan
and he's reported on elections all over
the world from liberia to taiwan
but last year major world events came
right to his doorstep
so he had a really unique perspective on
the 2020 election
the bitter divisions and the ways that
people were calling into question the
whole democratic process and kind of
undermining
things publicly i always judged that as
something that could never happen in the
united states
and so when i saw early on
you know the president saying publicly
that
you know we don't know if we can trust
the democratic process
it all felt like something i
had seen but couldn't have imagined it
would happen in the united states
david actually road trip to dc his road
trip
started in minneapolis that's where he
lives and
that was ground zero for last year's
protests i began
at george floyd square it seemed like
the most
natural starting point because you know
george floyd was killed on 38th in
chicago and
it sort of rippled across the country in
the world so i thought that that would
be
a really um important
sort of launching point
david said something else that was
really interesting there's this
grassroots effort to preserve the place
where george floyd was killed
as a memorial so david told the
protesters
who still occupy that intersection he
was starting this road trip there
and they said it made all the sense in
the world like where else would you
start
i drove across the state of wisconsin
like hitting very rural areas
you know where i saw during the
elections the bitter divisions between
people who i'd you know grown up with
everything from
the wearing of masks politics
to guns to
you know whose lives matter to science
what i saw in rural wisconsin was
sort of the leftover remnants of the
election
trump campaign posters
trump painted on the sides of bales of
hay
in farm fields it definitely is
i've lived in this area for quite some
time i've never seen a city like this
out on the streets over the last few
days it was difficult to find
many trump supporters but i ran into one
this morning would you be willing to
talk to me for a minute
uh interview he was wearing an nra cap
and we had just passed through one of
the many checkpoints
and we're walking past boarded up shops
toward the parade room you might tell me
your name he told me his name was bob
from maryland her last name
and he'd come to see the new president
make the traditional journey down
pennsylvania avenue he made it clear
that he disagreed with the attack on the
capitol
but he said he supported the right of
the trump supporters to protest the
election i think that was totally
american to do
there was nothing wrong with them doing
that and expressing their opinion
we're having the transfer of power here
and but
our society is divided so far i don't
think this is over
you're going to see a lot of
demonstrations in the street and this is
what it's going to be
troops plywood windows yeah
we as a society have gone different ways
okay we've lost a common moral
uh form not coming back
the country is certainly divided and it
feels like it probably will be for some
time
but at least today things were peaceful
and orderly
so amy how do you think history is going
to remember this
uh i think we're a little too close to
it
like to be right yeah so um with that
great with that caveat
i mean tensions have been really running
high for the last two weeks you know but
we're sitting here tonight
after all is said and done and the
inauguration went well
you know the only unexpected thing was
some snow
so you know first and foremost too
there's a milestone
kamala harris became the first black
person first asian american the first
woman to become vice president
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do solemnly swear
i kamala davey harris you soundly swear
that i will support and defend
the constitution of the united states
and i will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states against
all enemies foreign and domestic against
all enemies
foreign and domestic that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same that i take this
obligation
freely and i take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge that i will
well
and faithfully discharge the duties of
the office on which i am about to enter
the duties of the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god all right
yeah and so this is something i was
really interested to ask nina berman
about
she told me she's been thinking a lot
about kamala harris leading up to the
inauguration
here's how she put it well i feel that
kamala harris got a little cheated to be
quite honest because i think that
that it would have been an amazing
celebration i think that you would have
seen all those constituencies
coming out for her and being present on
the mall and having
parties and having all these things so
hopefully people are doing that in their
homes but we do not see
or i have not seen anything like that on
the streets of dc
well my daughter and i raised a glass to
the first madame vice president and
second gentleman
so we did have an amazing person a
celebration at home
[Music]
okay probably the key event to any
inauguration is the new president's
speech
which historians spend years
scrutinizing and quoting and all the
things that you know
making you write masters theses on so
what makes a good inaugural address
you know from a historian's point of
view it's tough to say
usually the ones that get remembered are
the ones that are
given during times of crises or the ones
that have
really good quotes fdr the only thing we
have to fear is fear itself
but what what makes a good one and
there's not any magic formula
um but it seems like they're themes the
things that they talk about and it's
it all tends to come back to unity it
comes back to this idea
of we as americans having our
differences
but still coming together as being
american
so i think it was safe to say that biden
was gonna talk about unity
um that was a pretty safe bet and you
hear echoes of these other presidents in
his address
you know washington's warnings about
factions lincoln's better angels
there's some great nods to franklin
roosevelt as well but the answer is not
to turn inward
to retreat into competing factions
distrusting those who don't look like
look like you
or worship the way you do or don't get
their news from the same sources you do
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal we can do
this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
if we show a little tolerance and
humility
and if we're willing to stand in the
other person's shoes as my mom would say
just for a moment stand in their shoes
because here's the thing about life
there's no accounting for what fate will
deal you
some days when you need a hand
there are other days when we're called
to lend a hand
that's how it has to be it's what we do
for one another
and if we are this way our country will
be stronger
more prosperous more ready for the
future
so amy with the world looking on and our
photographers documenting
the process the united states continued
its peaceful transition of power
you know which is the most important
piece of this whole thing
and it's a chain that's been unbroken
for more than two centuries
you know when you look back over those
two centuries you realize that
it hasn't always been the democrats and
the republicans
you know in u.s history political
parties have come and gone
federalists democratic republicans whigs
free soilers
the bull moose party i mean they all
have been a part of this dance we have
every four years
and no matter their beliefs at the end
of it
they united behind the elected president
my fellow americans
to a few of us here today this is a
solomon most momentous occasion we come
together as one nation
under god indivisible america has
carried on not simply
because of the skill or vision of those
in high office
but because we the people
have remained faithful to the ideals of
our forbearers
every four years we gather on these
steps to carry out the orderly and
peaceful transfer of power
as we have for more than two centuries
for a history of presidential
inaugurations you can look at our show
notes where we'll link to my article
on past inaugural addresses it
highlights some wise words leaders use
to unite us in troubled times
amy mckeever's piece on fraught
presidential transitions is another
great read
you can also see nina berman and david
gutenfelder's photography
in articles about president biden's
inauguration and what the nation's
capital looked like days before the
ceremony
and we'll also have a link to louis
palou's video of the january 6th attack
on the capitol
and make sure to subscribe to overheard
and listen to our episode last season
where i talked with photographer andrea
bruce about the meaning of democracy
that's in the show notes right there in
your podcast app
overheard's inauguration episode was
produced by jacob pinter
who also played the role of george
washington our senior editor is eli
chen executive producer of audio's davar
ardalan who also edited this episode
special thanks to brian gutierrez who
played abraham lincoln
our fact checker is julie beer our copy
editor is amy kolczak
ted woods sound designed and engineered
this episode
hansdale's sue composed our theme music
thanks to the white house
the ronald reagan presidential library
and the richard nixon presidential
library
for the archival tape in this episode
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
i'm peter guinn and i'm amy briggs
thanks for listening
and we'll see y'all soon
[Music]
you